in this episode we're going to deploy an
angular 4 app to firebase hosting after
some initial configuration you can
deploy your app to firebase in a matter
of seconds the best part is that it's
free for low-volume usage and to be
prepared to scale up because your app
grows running the ng build command will
compile and minify your code into a
single package located in the distal der
you could drop the contents with
directory into virtually any static
hosting platform or even an s3 bucket
and your site would be ready to serve
traffic right away firebase has a nice
command-line package for deployment
install it with NPM then login to your
firebase account from the command-line
make sure you're in the top-level
directory of your angular app then run
firebase in it this will take you
through a one-time configuration career
app for the most part you can stick with
the default settings except in these
following cases choose hosting on the
first question change the public folder
to disk when asked because that will be
equal to public configure is a single
page app answer yes if firebase asked to
overwrite your index.html file respond
with no
now your app should be ready to deploy
run the firebase deploy command then
check the project URL but it gives back
to you to make sure everything looks
good that's all for firebase deployment
see you next time
[Music]